qui a déjà fait des placements de
produits jamais en vrai moi j'en ai fais
tu fais quoi pour pour une marque de
cosmétiques dont je suis et j'ai ri
accord ouais m'arrive souvent de poster
pour cette marque aulas sait tous que
pour une marque tu fais une ou deux
marques ouais d'accord guillot jamais de
la vie jamais de la vie pourquoi bel et
bien des crevards je n'aime pas trop
les
métiers influenceurs c'est vraiment le
physique âgée c'est pas un métier moi
j'en ai marre du système d'instagram de
l'apologie du vide eu rien qu'on arrête
de dire qu'un film et qui se posait en
string devant une piscine et rien [ __ ]
de ces journées c'est pas un métier mais
créent du contenu par exemple l'union
mais ça va dans le sens d'un artiste non
mais ça en vrai ça n'a rien à voir
arrêter les influenceurs en vrai il y en
a qui ont du talent sur la personnalité
qu'ils ont de l'humour la plupart ils
n'ont aucun talent et mais il est
marquant wallon ses soucis alors il met
en fait ils mettent leur notoriété au
service et cyril vous trouvez ça normal
que des gens qui n'ont aucun talent qui
ne foutent rien de leur journée soit
payé cent mille euros par mois alors que
les gens il se lève à 6h le matin je
m'excuse c'est un business model qui est
comme ça et tant mieux pour ceux qui en
profitent comme magali parce que magali
elle elle bosse par exemple j'ai pas du
tout m'attaque à magali en revanche je
n'en peux plus de cette apologie du rien
c'est un modèle terry pour la jeunesse
que ces gens là il bossait comme tout le
monde et qu'on arrête de les mêmes
du fait de benjamin comme sa famille
tu peux pas nier qu'il ya mais non mais
elle a beaucoup qui pensent comme
biomasse
mais sauf que c'est tu parles d'une
minorité qu'on voit énormément mais il
ya aussi une majorité de oui mais bon il
ya un peu plus d un rien ils travaillent
pas ils foutent rien leur journée ils
payent rien y lâche pas un euro ils ont
une valeur ils sont insupportables
sur une échelle
[Applaudissements]
c'est un point de vue c'est un point
utile moi c'est les escroqueries qui
motive je lui en veux tu en parles après
mais j'ai rejoint guillaume sur le fait
que la vacuité le vide au bout d'un
moment c'est insupportable et c'est pour
ça que système aussi est en péril mais
parce que les gens en ont marre du vide
c'est à dire qu'ils se disent ces
gens-là nous vendre du vide en plus on
en parlera nous arnaquent
potentiellement donc arrêtons je pense
que ce système là est allé au bout voilà
le valérie est ce que j'en ai fait des
placements moi j'étais
je suis un peu l'émission
j'ai vidé de ses sirènes de police et
mal en jeu
ce que je disais non parce que je te
disais c'est à dire que ce qu'est ce qui
m'ennuie c'est qu'on met tout le monde
dans le même sac et qu'on dise que
globalement c'est des escrocs etc il ya
forcément dans l'eau des escrocs des
gens qui font pas bien leur métier comme
dans tenir voilà et il ya des gens je
suis plein d'amis blatter télé je trouve
qu'ils font un travail physique de la
scène mais je sais que l'ena situation
vous avez invité l'adorent qui fait
kiffer qui craignent qu'on a vu que la
tournée qui fait un réel modèle
économique et qui trompe
pas les oreilles j'ai un travail qui se
lèvent le matin qu'ils fassent un boulot
qui gagne le smic et d'autres gens qui
n'ont aucun talent qu'ils foutent rien
qu'ils sont prêts à tout pour gagner de
l'argent arnaquer les gens à mentir
c'est à dire des films journaux pour
certains et qui gagne 100 mille euros
par mois ça ça m'exaspère
[Applaudissements]
castanet guillaume t bravo c'est bien
des vagues walk to meet you tube et dans
le dos tu mélanges ceux qui font du mime
ceux qui font des idées qui on découvrit
mon tort qu il y en avoir effectivement
c'est dégoûtant entre guillemets que
l'on gagne autant d'argent mais tous
sont pas nulles pourquoi t'es-tu
généralistes comme toujours le real et
ses oublis ou noir en fait c'est ça fait
beaucoup de démagogie non ils sont
difficiles à manier alors là il n'a pas
de démagogie préfet que ça je
sais pas si c'est tout
bien sûr ils sont prêts à tout pour deux
là mais c'est d'éduquer certains sont
prêts à tout avec les enfants sont ils
vont au resto ils veulent pas payer il
s'achète un tee shirt ils veulent un tee
shirt il le paye pas mon truc c'est
normal c'est ce que vient de perdre une
année à toi qui font pareil équipe à
restaurant militaire en vacances qui
missionné internet justement tavares
castaldi le grahter alors jouer
justement le gâteau rien du tout on
n'est pas raison de dénoncer
l'escroquerie toi y'a des escroqueries
toit d un
problème la publicité parce que la
cité
moi je ne suis pas quelqu'un d'aigri je
suis pas quelqu'un de jaloux mais ça me
met mal à l'aise que quelqu'un qui n'ait
rien foutu de sa ville soit passé une
fois dans la villa des coeurs brisés et
ça pour moi 150000 euros par mois
gagnent le salaire d'un grand patron ou
dix fois ou vingt fois quelqu'un se fait
chier à se lever tous les matins il ya
le discours
delphine j'ai enfin quand même ça booste
quand même un peu l'économie dans le
sens où tu dit le gars il va au resto il
paye pas mais fine story en vrai le
restaurateur cc bild on l'a vu il ya
aucun rendement là dessus tout le
flec parce que c'est une énorme arnaque
c'est tout
dalpé battu le fait ou pas mais d'être
fier c'est delphine elle vient de la
télé elle est connue parce qu'elle fait
de la télé mais en fait ce sont des pans
les personnalités que tu suis pas
rigoler parce que les produits que je
présente aux gens c'est que des produits
naturels produits qui me ressemble éco
citoyens et tous à machin et donc les
gens qui me suivent pour ça et donc ils
découvrent des produits c'est sur ce que
tu suis je ne sais pas qui tu vas avoir
100 dans mutations avec éléphant cie
c'est vrai que ce consommateur un long
ballon
[Rires]
leur idole quelle est leur modèle au
bout d'un moment
de leur autorité qu'ils influencent dans
le mauvais sens du terme une jeunesse
qui est qui et naïve et qui est prête à
tout et qui en plus le pire c'est que
l'on glisse un modèle de réussite c'est
également aujourd'hui même pu être
acteurs ils veulent plus de footballeurs
et des influenceurs
monfils qui avait influencé pour bien
travailler tuera
il m'a influencé les autres et nature à
calmer oui ce qui m'énerve un peu chez
ben c'est ma fille qui va être influencé
ce qui m'énerve un peu chez benjamin et
delphine valérie aussi c'est que
c'est que en fait vous êtes dans le
système mais je ne nie pas moi aussi je
suis sans doute dans le système même je
défends d'invendus bernès oui mais font
pas tout - que vous défendez qui vous
nourrit et donc en fait nous revenir
chez
moi j'ai fait deux fois j'étais gérer
deux fois de deux marques sur des
vêtements et consécutive
pour les produits bio de nourriture
parce que j'adore faire la cuisine et il
faisait des recettes je fais des
recettes et je les présente à m'excuser
car oui
d'essence parce que c'est un
corresponsant me ressemble je suis en
accord avec la marque et je vérifie gt
gt rencontre gt2 en gt2 en égérie choqué
non je n'en peux te dire que ça se
passait pas comme ça et je vends pas un
truc des blanchiments dedans on ne sait
pas quoi où je sais pas d'où ça vient de
chine ne sais pas quoi et vous nous avez
vu aussi énervé parce que ça vous touche
mais je pense
qu'il a tout changé la donne
marc est celle que je chantais tout oui
mais nommés n'ont jamais été si vous
bougez pas vous devez tenir compte de ce
qui se dit vous devez tenir compte des
personnes et
des problèmes on voit déjà de ma gagné
magali dupont aignan nous parler est ce
qu'il y à des malversations
d'israël sans vouloir défendre les
affluences ans parce qu'elle fait bien
sûr ma défont les pages appartient il
quand même sinon j'attends la force des
choses parce que je fais des vidéos sur
glace que cet argent très d'accord avec
guillaume sur le fait que ben oui c'est
bien sûr mais par contre faut pas
oublier aussi que il ya des influenceurs
parfois qu'ils sont un peu victimes des
marques frauduleuse je moi je vérifie
toujours les marques avec limoges et
boussac des grandes marques et une fois
ça m'arrivait de moins vérifiées de
poster le truc et après de me rendre
compte que c'était une artiste il y
avait personne n'est pas de boîte
derrière y avait rien et après pendant
une semaine tu te prends des gens qui
t'insultent dans tous les sens et si
tous les influenceurs voulait faire des
arnaques annonce a extrait pas parce que
t'as pas envie de te faire insulter ta
grand mère pendant une semaine bien sûr
tout le monde il se dit que c'est un
gros vent des insultes et cinq ans je
pense
c'est un daniel daniel et grand-mère de
plaintes
est insupportable